chris jones the chief's defensive
lineman a key part of that team
a guy that they need to keep around a
guy that it looked like maybe they would
not get a long-term deal
done with a guy who was making noise
about sitting out
the entire season none of that will
happen because a long-term deal
is in place a four-year deal contrast
with the 12-year contract that patrick
holmes signed last week four years
80 million dollars that's 20 million per
year i'm told it's the same basic
structure as the home deals with
functional guarantees that make it
harder to cut him
here's the cash flow as i understand
it's 16.126 million in year one
21.5 million in year two 22.374 million
in year three and 20 million
in year four of that amount
55.75 million fully guaranteed it's
signing and then that's roughly
70 of the deal likewise being fully
guaranteed by the second year of the
contract
so look this guy's good enough they're
not going to let him go he got a
four-year deal
it's always smart to do a shorter term
and get back
to the table because by the time you get
to
year three four five anyway of a
long-term deal
if the team isn't happy with how you're
performing
they're gonna tear it up they're gonna
squeeze you to take less they're only
gonna keep that deal going
if they think it's a good deal for them
because it's a one-way contract
after you get past those first few years
mahomes has decided to commit
for 12 jones commits for four no
guarantee he's still going to be a
superstar in four years
but again if he wasn't a superstar in
four years and he signed for longer than
that
they would just rip the deal up and move
on so
good news for the chiefs they're holding
it all together
jones goes on to twitter and says the
chiefs are building
a dynasty and that kind of reminds me of
the vince young dream team remarks from
nine years ago look
you're already going to be the hunted
you're already going to be
a team that everyone is trying to knock
off and you learned last year
how hard it is to ultimately win the
whole thing
the chiefs needed to come from behind in
every one
of their playoff wins double digit
come from behind in every one of their
postseason wins including
in the super bowl down 10 points with
seven minutes left in the game so
be careful because it is still difficult
even with the greatest quarterback in
the nfl and even with a tremendous
defensive lineman like chris jones it is
still
incredibly difficult to win a super bowl
championship
and in most cases you give me the
defending champion or the field
i'm taking the field and this year i'm
definitely taking the field because
there's too much
craziness going on in the nfl to feel
good about
anybody being able to solve whatever it
is
that the nfl is going to have thrown at
it between the normal uncertainty
that any team faces and the extra layer
buttons
of uncertainty arising from the pandemic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports